In these 26 years of life I have had
mentors and people who have helped me
develop those technical skills
to develop an interest in
space exploration,
but my mother was the one who instilled in me from a
very young age that strength to
overcome obstacles so that I could
achieve  my dream
[Music]
in space exploration has always
caught my attention because it is like the
next frontier, which is unknown to
the space engineer
[Music]
today I have to work with
machinery that is going to try to
help us  understand the living beings on
this planet earth we are the only ones in
the universe
[Music]
but
not
[Music]
it was not Ecuador in 1993 and I was here
for more or less four years and my
mother had worked all her life  As a
teacher, she was the director of one of the
schools in Guayaquil at that time
when the situation became very difficult.
Luckily, we won the lottery to educate
and all that, and how can they be converted?  nir to
the usa
there is no erc the very expensive rents that
we saw in a studio was very difficult and i
miss my friends because a good
six months and now you go
[Music]
my mom with all her courage and bravery well
start again from scratch where
again she didn't know the language so
she worked cleaning offices but she
never stopped and she always did it
simply for the sake of looking good
and now I'm with my hands touching
machinery that one day is going to go to
space I think it's very important
for  us to be examples for the
community and say look here if you
can do what you set out to do you have
to work
[Music]
traveling in space means you have to
create months inside a small
capsule I think that the most
difficult obstacles that we are going to  to face is going to be getting
so far away from what we know getting
away from our families getting away from
our lands being isolated from what
makes us so comfortable on earth
[Music]
my mom never knows what  I live
and that strengthened us as a family
in a certain way we never lacked for anything
because we didn't know
[Music]
how you are
and this beautiful man
the truth is how many beautiful things
good
[Music]
extracting properties